aujourd'hui on joue aux jeux vidéo avec
mon père je suis pas ton père à gauche
et adopté au chaland cbg freiner et à
s'avancer en sens inverse
shadow et le tournis kambewa avait roulé
sur une manette mais je me suis parti
sur une banane alors
parce que madame canton
ouais écoute moi je ferais premier non
car je suis trop regardé jouer fautes
rapides quand même
donc tout est dit la tient à inventer je
vais rester à un mobile a vu nul
pourrait en tu restes sur la route
arrivé je suis très fière de toi c'est
la première game était arrivé quand même
bat arrivé et j'ai collé cubes en place
je sais pas quoi donc des cubes en glace
et les petits cadeaux à les molettes
attendent et je te perds ma surprise
d'accord allez c'est moi qui t'ai jeter
ça excellent généreux tirer sur les
faibles alors plaisir en fait je me sens
handicapés ah ouais c'est comme si je
suis handicapé hop je rassure t pas du
tout aux handicapés j'étais juste un peu
mieux aller j'ai déjà beaucoup d'argent
a changé de siècle et que c'est quoi ton
jeu vidéo préféré quand tu étais petit
le flipper qui est donc pas un jeu vidéo
ah non à toi tu peux parler discuter
vraiment un progamer dans la vraie vie
je peux faire des trucs dans ma voiture
téléphoner par exemple
voilà père il maîtrise bien ma voiture
donc ça c'est un autre jeu tu vas voir
très simple by plus au match manger bien
bon ça pas comment c'est encore un tout
et luigi toi ouais le jilbab côté et
mario mario been hockey au pilote ayant
à sa tête pourquoi la lampe peut taper
dans les caisses c'est au top dans une
pièce
j'ai raté à guyot hop hop apparemment
totem les tuyaux vraiment un truc ans
handicapé je suis dans ma bulle
dans ma vie dans ma bulle quoi dans la
bulle c'est un album de diam's qui n'est
venu
- astique qui est devenue musulmane on
en parle jules marie person l'aps et
elle est devenue musulmane musulmane
j'étais pas loin regarde prix ok c'est
parti ravi ce que je dis là l'art
nikitina amsatou peu comme l'indiqué
côté fait match aux allures à la teneur
ça veut dire il est un cadre l'oeil du
caca on parle de cacao lingala si tu
veux c'est par le lingala
bref m beauté c'est bonjour et par les
deux bouts jobin d'accord ça veut dire
je crois que ça veut dire
conner donc en bon je veux dire bonjour
connard fois c'est ce que je peux dire
donc très bas
bonjour connard c'est vraiment un truc
jamais caressé pas du film black toi as
tu veux qu'on parle de ça avec la caméra
lui mais c'est vraiment un sujet de
discussion à que tu va aborder
bah oui ouais j'aime toutes les toutes
les types de femmes que les couleurs
temps quelque temps qu'ils acceptent
cette annonce est là bas beaucoup de
fait pose quoi ça suffit à partir la
pause mais je prêtais de plusieurs
pauses hamas à l'est où il refait pause
pause attend on va dizaine d'hommes
adore ça pose à temps mais pas beaucoup
plus de points que moi à rebours nom est
totalement premier temps je suis dégoûté
je quitte je quitte pato au g4 cloche
et ouais je sais pas où je me dis que tu
pas toutes pièces mais non comme un fort
boyard
je suis pas aux chevilles battez le mec
avec une couronne t mario adacore mario
je sais pourquoi il ya plus les plus les
petites voitures la ctu mario kart ça
c'est un autre jeu ça a pas d'accord
c'est pas mélanger je fais un petit
pique nique norman pas papa papa ben on
a fini le troisième stage eyes the
winner is the winner n'en aie and the
winner is the winner il faut tirer le
requin comme ça et le faire lui faire
manger des pièces
donc on se charrie le parc à tous les
deux ouais même pas quatre comme tu dit
la plaquette ipad à la plaque rétail
paille depuis très très belle plaquette
aussi reçu cinq ans je passais sous la
baignoire un plat les mandats fait ce
niveau mais c'est un peu
surréaliste à contrôler bourgoin tire
une coup d'arrêt au caire pour bouffer
des pièces on dit merci aux internautes
enfin merci l'heure sur la vidéo ciao et
signifie quelqu'un veut se mesurer à mon
père je crois qu'il hopper
il se bat les couilles
allez ciao et plein de métiers au tout
pas employer les guillemets tu vas faire
je présente c'est moi votre chirurgien
ouais je m'occupais personnellement de
votre crêpe du coeur